كل فتره بنسمع عن قصه مؤلمه لزواج
القاصرات في اليمن ونوها جميل علي حيدر
طفله يمنيه عمرها 10 سنوات ضحيه جديده من
ضحايا زواج القاصرات في اليمن تم تزويجها
من بعد تزوير وثائقها الرسميه وتحديدا
عمرها من قبل والدها والقصه ان الطفله نهى
عائشه مع امها وزوج امها وسافرت مع زوج
امها علشان تشوف ابوها وتتعرف عليه لانها
ما بتعرفه ابدا وابوها زوجها من بعد ما
زور عمرها في الوثائق الرسميه وبعد شهور
من البحث عنها اكتشفوا الموضوع وتم
القراءه القبض على الاب والزوج والامين
الشرعي وقدره المحكمه فسخ عقد الزواج
واعاده البنت لامها وهذي القصه عملت غضب
واسعه بين الاوساط اليمنينيه وصدرها
هاشتاج اكبر جريمه بحق الطفوله من الصوت
والناس طالبوا بمعاقبه كل من له يد في
حرمانها من طفولتها
[موسيقى]